[موسيقى]
التفكير في ما يحدث في
طبقك الآن يمكن أن يساعدك على التفكير
في المستقبل ، حيث تشير بعض الدراسات إلى أن
الفراولة والتوت الأزرق يمكن أن يساعدا في
تأخير تدهور الذاكرة وتحسين وظائف المخ ،
وخاصة بالنسبة لكبار السن ،
ووجدت دراسة أخرى أن النساء اللائي تناولن المزيد من
الخضار الورقية والصليبية
الأحماض الدهنية النباتية العائلية التي
ترتبط على المدى الطويل بتحسين الذاكرة وتحسين
القدرة على التعلم وتباطؤ
التدهور المعرفي ويمكن أن يساعد الكافيين والقهوة
والشاي في تكوين ذكريات جديدة وقد
يقلل من أداء الدماغ المتدهور
والحصول على هذا البيض غني بمغذيات مهمة
تسمى الكولين  وجدت إحدى الدراسات أن
الأشخاص الذين تناولوا كميات كبيرة من
الكولين خضعوا لفحوصات التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي
لأدمغتهم إذا لم تأكل البيض.